[Music]
what if a child dreamed of becoming
something other than what society
what if a child aspired to something
greater
not so fast Superman we've got to talk
to you about your dues yeah you know or
all I've just been really busy saving
people and I'm really too busy to pay
dues to the union that allows you to be
a superhero to begin with allows I'd
only have any of these problems with
Aquaman a shark attack probably pay your
dues yeah it says here that you are
faster than a speeding bullet more
powerful than a locomotive
and can leap tall buildings in a single
bound but you just want to put everyone
in town out of work what do you want
from me I have a gift Earl you selfish
[ __ ] your SuperSpeed is literally like
taking the food out of the mouths of
Flash's kids I just want to save people
that's it well that's why we're now
camping it to a-1 power for superhero
maximum calling it the fan of rule so
pick which one you want you can have the
x-ray vision you can have the frost
frying one flight power flight good
choice okay so that is gonna be at a
maximum of 70 miles per hour what we
can't have your back door and your
SuperSpeed and by flying supersonic I
told you you get one power don't worry
I'll save you oh no you're not you're
officially off duty she's gonna die
Aquaman this is her all we have a 492 in
progress please respond no listen I get
it okay you're the Man of Steel I
understand how it goes but uh you don't
want anything to happen to that pretty
little Lois yours right you don't want
anyone to know your real name Clark you
should probably pay your dues unions are
the worst well you know that's just what
Spiderman said when I redistricting him
last week there yeah I don't know
nothing about that but Manhattan's too
crowded
we've gotta move you to Queens
[Music]
[Music]